versteckt hinter bäumen liegt der
beschauliche sachsen see er gilt als
geheimtipp und in dieser idylle sucht
jetzt wasserschutzpolizei und
spezialtaucher nach der leiche von
daniel matissek seine mörder sollen ihn
in obi ein mann einbetoniert und dann im
see versenkt haben von der leiche aber
fehlt bis heute jede spur
der junge mann hinter mir auf dem
monitor der geht seit 2016 als vermisst
und dieser vermisstenfall ist in
wahrheit ein mordfall in zwei männer die
sollen daniel erst entführt und dann
ermordet haben tja und jetzt fragen sich
alle wo ist seine leiche und es gibt da
einen verdacht denn womöglich liegt die
leiche auf dem grund eines sees
zerstückelt und einbetoniert in zehn obi
ein mann an diesem see da waren jetzt
spezialtaucher im einsatz und unsere
reporterin nina zander die war mit dabei
der sachsen see südlich von gießen in
hessen großeinsatz für die einsatzkräfte
die außentemperatur 4 grad im eiskalten
wasser läuft die suche nach den
leichenteilen von daniel matissek
erschossen zerstückelt und in obi eimern
einbetoniert so soll matysik ermordet
worden sein doch von der leiche fehlt
jede spur diesen unglaublichen
kriminalfall muss zurzeit das
landgericht gießen klären angeklagt sind
olaf c und robert s nach unseren
bisherigen erkenntnissen soll es so
gewesen sein dass beide angeklagten das
opfer zu hause abgeholt haben und zwar
unter einem vorwand nämlich dass man
sich eine immobilie in hungen
bellersheim anschauen will und entweder
während der fahrt oder auf dem gehöft in
bellersheim soll es dann zur
schussabgabe gekommen sein und dann
sollte an die längst verstorben sein
bellersheim in hessen 17 november 2016
die drei freunde daniel matissek olaf c
und robert es haben große pläne ein
historisches gehofft wollen sie zu einem
swingerclub ausbauen drei
geschäftspartner sechs jahre ist das her
und plötzlich fehlt von daniel matissek
jede spur achtung fahndung reporterin
lena sander macht sich auf die suche am
tag seines verschwindens holten seine
freunde ihn hier von zu hause ab daniel
matissek stieg in das auto und
verschwand für immer
laut der gießener staatsanwaltschaft
entführten die beiden mutmaßlichen täter
daniel matissek um geld von dessen
vermögen der familie zu erpressen
nachdem die beiden männer matissek vor
dessen wohnung in hanau mit dem auto
abgeholt hatten und richtung bellersheim
fuhren fiel im ford fiesta von robert es
ein tödlicher schuss wer von den beiden
männern abgedrückt hat unklar beide
tatverdächtigen belasten sich
gegenseitig nach dem urlaub sie und
robert es den vollkommen ahnungslosen
daniel m im auto erschossen hatten
sondern sich hierher gefahren sein um
die leiche zu zerstückeln die knochen
von daniel matissek sei robert es
zunächst versucht haben mit einem
bunsenbrenner zu verbrennen als das
nicht funktionierte soll er sie im 10
obi einer einbetoniert und nach eigenen
aussagen im starnberger see versenkt
haben
bis 2020 blieb alles ruhig und daniel
matissek galt lediglich als vermisst
doch dann ging mathelehrer ofc zur
polizei und gestand er und robert es
hätten matissek entführt und getötet
nach bild informationen soll der mord
olaf c so sehr belastet haben dass er
mit der schuld nicht mehr leben konnte
und sein schweigen brach
es kommt zum großeinsatz am ehemaligen
hof von robert s die neuen besitzer sind
schockiert achtung fahndung liegt der
durchsuchungsbeschluss vor mit dem sich
die polizei damals zugang verschaffte
mit presslufthammer und schwerem gerät
wird der betonboden imhof aufgebrochen
auf der suche nach matti sechs leiche
zentimeter für zentimeter wird das
anwesen durchkämmt aber aus einem
blutstropfen finden die beamten nichts
reporterin lena zander trifft die neue
besitzerin also das war schon am anfang
ziemlich schlimm und dann nahm er
erledigt sein münchen im raum rhein bin
und geguckt hat hat sie mir da
vielleicht liegt der bisher wochen nach
der durchsuchung wird robert es
verhaftet olaf c kommt ebenfalls in u
haft seit april 2021 stehen beide vor
dem landgericht gießen die anklage
lautet mord robert es schweigt bei der
verhandlung ofc hat ausgesagt allerdings
nicht wer geschossen hat und auch nicht
wo sich die leiche befindet
seit vergangener woche gehen die
ermittler einer neuen spur nach der
anwalt der familie von daniel matissek
hatte beantragt nachdem ob man mit den
leichenteilen im hessischen sachsen see
zu suchen der see ist nur wenige
kilometer vom wahrscheinlichen tatort
dem hof in bellersheim entfernt und
robert es ging dort nachweislich tauchen
umstand dass wenn es ein abgeschlossenes
verfahren gibt und die leiche bis dahin
nicht gefunden wurde das dann es
voraussichtlich für die eltern nie eine
chance geben wird deren sohn beerdigen
zu können sich von ihnen verabschieden
zu können
dass er schwingt mit dieser neuen suche
schon oder geht mit dieser neuen sind
wir schon ein heer das darf man also auf
emotionaler ebene was jetzt die
nebenkläger die eltern anbelangt
muss man das auch aus deren sicht schon
gewichten so dass das für die auch ein
letzter hoffnungsschimmer ist sich von
ihrem sohn verabschieden zu können
bundeswehr taucher polizei und feuerwehr
im großeinsatz am sachsen sie unsere
reporterin begleitet die suche werden
die experten hier die überreste von
daniel matissek finden wir können nur
das finden was auch wirklich da ist
suchen wir jedes mal macht das ja nicht
unsere erste suche oder unser erstes der
amtshilfe für die polizei zwei tage lang
suchen die experten bislang ergebnislos
die suchaktion am sachsen sie ist jetzt
vorläufig beendet wir haben mit
modernster technik auffälligkeiten im
see gesehen es waren nur wenige punkte
aber es gab welche die mussten wir
natürlich nachgehen dementsprechend
haben wir über eine firma ein
tauchroboter einsetzen lassen dieser
tauchroboter also anhand von bildern
konnte man sehen dass sich dort indem
sie steine gefunden gefunden haben und
steinplatten mit abrundung die so
ähnlich sein könnten wie im eimer jetzt
wird die suche mit tauchern fortgesetzt
und die leiche von daniel matissek
endlich zu finden bisher wird das urteil
im märz erwartet weil es bis dahin
termine gibt aber falls die eimer mit
den einbetonierten teilnimmt see
gefunden werden wird die verhandlung
weiter gehen und über diesen fall wollen
wir weiter sprechen mit dr constantinis
sie zurück im studio ist frau nis wir
haben gehört diese leiche sie wurde
zerstückelt und dann eben womöglich in
zehn ein mann im see versenkt das ist
jetzt sechs jahre her was würde denn der
beton und das wasser mit den sterblichen
überresten der zeit machen also in beton
eingegossen und im tiefen see versenkt
bedeutet kein sauerstoff mehr und kühl
gelagert und unter diesen umständen sind
die natürlichen verwesung und folgendes
prozesse erheblich gedrosselt und
sistieren auch relativ schnell so dass
es durchaus möglich ist dass eine
gewisse konservierung eintritt da unten
so ähnlich wie ich habe mal hin modell
mitgebracht diese ein gegossene in harz
eingegossenen ihre die ja auch schon
seit vielen jahren
trainer existiert und ich gehe mal davon
aus dass noch so eine art verwesung eben
erhalte neben stattgefunden hat was
allerdings was man weiß da unten
passiert und dass sauerstoff aus schluss
ist eine versteifung des fettgewebes ist
körpereigenen fettgewebes das führt dann
zu so eine schmierig wächsernen substanz
wieder besser macht von fett wachs
leichen spricht das heißt also das
gewebe wird wohl höchstwahrscheinlich
noch relativ verhalten sein aber eben
nicht mehr ganz frisch wenn jetzt am
ende taucht tatsächlich diese eimer
finden würden da sind also sterbliche
überreste drin eingegossen in beton wie
geht das dann weiter wie werden die
geborgen wann und wie würde sowas zu
ihnen auf den tisch kommen ja ich denke
dass die rechtsmediziner bei der bergung
auf jeden fall schon vor ort sind um
sich einen ersten eindruck zu
verschaffen zum beispiel auch sind die
einmal beschädigt konnte dann vielleicht
doch noch luft oder wasser an die
leichenteile dran gelangen und danach
würde man die schnellstmöglich ins
institut transportieren denn man weiß
natürlich so bald wie der sauerstoff
drankommt luft dran kommt dann beginnt
das alles wieder mit diesen folgendes
veränderungen und die können teilweise
explosionsartig dann fortschreiten also
ist eile geboten und die rechtsmediziner
die neben den hammer und meißel und
hermann das auf oder wie kommt man an
die eigentlichen sterblichen überreste
ran also in dem fall wäre es sicher
empfehlenswert wenn man es vielleicht
vorher mal durchleuchtet diese einer
radiologisch kann man das machen
computertomographische untersuchungen
und dann wirst du mir zum beispiel auch
überhaupt was drin ist an gleichen
teilen und man hätte den erst befund
gesichert und danach könnten sie sich
daran machen eben die leichenteile zu
befreien wie und werde es dann macht das
würde man vor ort entscheiden sie auch
das schöne an unserem beruf haben immer
einzelfälle und da muss man schauen wie
man mit den umständen zurechtkommen
hatten sie selbst mal eine beton leichen
und einer form auf dem seziertisch vor
sich liegen
nicht wirklich ich hatte mal eine
beerdigt oder vergrabene leiche die war
in einem teppich eingerollt und nach
erschossen und da wurde eine
betonschicht drüber
betoniert und da hat sich aber jemand
daneben auch gemälde nachgesagt er liegt
eine aber na ja ansonsten sind es ja
eher mafia methoden und wir sind ja in
unserem beschaulichen hessen da haben
wir so was äußerst selten
sie sagen es macht ja methode daran
denkt man ja sofort wenn man hört mit
beton im wasser versenkt wie oft kommt
so was vor ist sowas nur filmstoff oder
tatsächlich sie haben ein bild
mitgebracht da geht es tatsächlich um
genau so ein mafia mord genau also bei
uns wenn wir das tatsächlich wirklich
sehr selten aber ich habe in meinem
fundus gekramt und das ist eben ein
einfall aus den usa aus der ostküste der
usa und man sieht hier eben eine
einbetonierte person geguckt noch in der
schädel raus und die wahre geschichte
die dazu erzählt wird ist das eben
wirklich jemand aber bei lebendigem
leibe mit beton übergossen wurde es aber
noch in so eine art gerüst und er hatte
tatsächlich eine tauchglocke über diese
öffnung um ja da gefriert auch mir
irgendwie das blut in den adern um das
eben möglichst noch mitzubekommen wie er
da versenkt wird und eben letztendlich
auch stehe darf ich sie abschließend
freuen wenn man jetzt alles mal revue
passieren lässt dann ist ja eigentlich
der beton und die einbetonierte leicht
macht es ihnen in der arbeit womöglich
ein stück weit leichter weil im wahrheit
die stur spuren besser erhalten werden
als ja wenn ich jemanden im wald
vergraben oder so in den see versenkt da
ist sicherlich einfacher wenn wir noch
weichgewebe haben statt eine komplett
skelettierte leiche so wie es hier
sicher andeutet aber auch an den knochen
über verletzungsspuren oder
werkzeugspuren oder englisch sehen aber
trotz alledem je mehr weichgewebe und je
mehr befunde leiche noch erhalten haben
und so mehr befunde können wir am ende
auch sicher ponys vielen dank dass sie
heute abend bei uns behandelt wie immer
danke für ihre expertise